in this video we'll talk about chlamydia
trichomatis and its stereotypes
this is a higher video for USMLE step
one stay tuned till the end
chlamydia trokomatis is a bacteria that
is well known for sexually transmitted
infection
this is the obligate intracellular
parasite of eukaryotic cell
they cannot make their own ATP and
that's why they are dependent
chlamydia has a peculiar feature in
terms of the cell wall the classical
peptidoglycans are lacking and they have
reduced muramic acid that is why
beta-lactam antibiotics are ineffective
on chlamydia this is very important from
a clinical point of view
let's see what kind of infection and
damages can be caused by chlamydia
trachomatis
these include neonatal and follicular
adult conjunctivitis
non-gonococcal urethritis reactive
arthritis and pelvic inflammatory
disease just to name a few
one of the important thing that is a
trachoma
is a devastating disease caused by
chlamydia
now trocoma is very common and caused by
the serotypes ABC
and this is common in low-income
countries where basically the
overall treatment procedure is not that
good and availability of reagents are
not good
now it can cause a chronic
keratoconjunctivitis that might lead to
blindness if untreated
so trachoma can be transmitted by
personal contact for example droplet
infection or let's say contamin touching
the contaminated surface and rubbing the
eyes henceforth
so there are different stages of
trachoma initially this is how the
normal eye look like and in the early
stages of trachoma there would be
intense inflammation then the there
would be scarring in the eyelids and
eventually there could be clouding in
the cornea and if untreated even at that
stage there could be blindness due to
trachoma and it happens in many
low-income countries like Africa
stereotypes D2K can also lead to other
type of infection
and it's mostly transmitted during birth
in general chlamydia infection can
Spread spread from mother to the baby
so when the in the time of delivery the
when the fetus is coming out of the
birth canal at that point of time the
baby can get infected with chlamydia
that is why neonatal conjunctivitis and
other infections are not so uncommon
these days
alongside that stereotypes D and K can
lead to pelvic inflammatory disease and
non-gonococcal urethritis
in women chlamydia can cause different
type of complication when it comes
compared to the men
so in women there could be pelvic
inflammatory disease chronic pelvic pain
infertility it might increase the
chances of ectopic pregnancy
or it can lead to premature birth or
miscarriage even
also reactive arthritis is additional
in case of main there could be
inflammation in the testicles epididymis
and it can lead to epididymo or chitis
then there could be reactive arthritis
which is pretty much common between male
and female as well and it can also lead
to inflammation in the rectum
now let's talk about and summarize the
serotype and the disease caused by them
so already we talked about the
stereotypes a b and c
and it lead to chronic inflammation
cause blindness due to follicular
conjunctivitis in resource limited areas
like in low-income countries in the
third world countries
Now The Stereotype DNK D2K they can lead
to generally urethritis pelvic
inflammatory disease ectopic pregnancy
that we talked about already and one
thing it's important that chlamydia can
be transmitted from mother to baby
during the time of delivery
then The Stereotype L1 L2 and L3 can
lead to
lymphogranuloma venerum a small painless
ulcer on genitals which are swollen
painful and that can lead to many other
complications
so basically the lymph node forms
bubble-like structure and ulcerates
and anyway these overall uh
symptoms can be treated with antibiotics
like doxycycline
so now let's see how trachoma is
transmitted obviously it's a sexually
transmitted disease so unprotected sex
multiple partners transmit it can also
transmit it during pregnancy which we
already looked or it can also be
transmitted during blood transfusion
so who are most likely to get infected
by chlamydia
generally the young women are more
vulnerable towards the infection with
chlamydia
but anybody can get affected be it a
mature male or female anybody can get
affected
now it's not really difficult to treat
because it's a bacterial infection can
be treated with antibiotic but detecting
the disease at proper time and proper
treatment is necessary
but there is a concerning outcome from
latest research because while other
sexually transmitted disease like
nissaria gonorary and syphilis have
plateaued over last 10 years
the incidence of chlamydia is increasing
which is pretty much concerning because
in early stages strokoma goes undetected
let's talk about the diagnosis in that
context
so how chlamydia can be detected most
strains of chlamydia trachomiosis can be
detected with monoclonal antibodies such
as vs4 or momp antibodies so basically
Elizabeth's test can be used to detect
them and always for any of these
bacteria
PCR based diagnosis though expensive can
be a better
a better sensitive and more High
throughput diagnosis in this case
let's talk about the treatment of
chlamydia obviously it's a bacterial
disease so it will be treated with
antibiotics so let's see what are the
antibiotics of choice
so generally clinician can try a broad
spectrum and antibacterial such as
azithromycin tetracycline
so these are the two ones which are in a
drug of choice other than that
erythromycin can be used in small
children and pregnant women because
um sometimes tetracycline can cause
calcification so in order to avoid that
erythromycin can be used
the question is are there antibiotic
resistant chlamydia strains and Recent
research shows that indeed there are
antibiotic resistant chlamydia strains
which are reported worldwide
and that's a matter of concern for the
clinicians
however it's also important that we
should know chlamydia pneumonia and
chlamydia ciccati can cause atypical
pneumonia and can be transmitted via
aerosol this is also important from an
exam point of view so I hope this video
was useful if you want more notes
flashcards visit our Instagram page
follow us on Facebook you can support
our Channel using super thanks you can
pay via PayPal paytm or UPI
so I'll see you in next video
[Music]